police in Italy have seized an arsenal
of weapons and 2.5 kilos of explosives
during a raid on what was described as a
mafia stronghold in the south of the
country over a kilo of cocaine was also
recovered this comes after a ruling by
the European Court of Human Rights that
said Italy would reform its justice
system it claims the country's prison
regime is too tough on mafia bosses who
refused to cooperate with authorities
the court has also pointed out there's
no way for inmates to get early release
if his legal system was toughened in the
wake of bloody mafia feuds in the 1980s
and 90s organized crime bosses are now
totally isolated in prison with no
contact allowed with inmates or with
people from outside following this
change in the law many started to
cooperate with the police
Italy's Vice Minister of Foreign Affairs
says other countries should match their
tough line and not expect to change it a
massive guy going out of the task reason
will keep on ruling demacia headquarters
at a yell in in the country we think
that the realities that we should do the
opposite I mean we should reinforce the
other country legislation against the
matter guys and not weaken our own one
the crime rate in Italy dropped since a
crackdown on the mafia in 1990s however
the syndicates continued to operate
there today particularly in its southern
regions people who spoke out against
organized crime now say they fear for
their lives
Guilhem enters one of these come to
andreyeva my life will be at risk if
Italy changes their prison terms because
I know the Mafia never forgets
we are the walking dead to them but I'd
rather live as a free man not as a slave
with all the problems that entails if I
had to go back I'd have made the same
choices all over again I'm against these
law changes they send a dangerous
message a man serving a life sentence
could be released despite committing
terrible crimes it sends the wrong
message to young people the Commission
should have thought about that movie
requested that be on July 30 the
European Court doesn't know our history
it is impossible to create a law for an
known situation is a mistake coming up
the problem with a lack of knowledge we
ask people in Sicily what they thought
about the ruling by the European Court
of Human Rights
unfortunately Italy and Sicily in
particular is known to be the homeland
of the Mafia we should be tightening
penalties for criminals not easing them
Europe shouldn't be deciding for us the
Mafia was born in Italy and only Italy
knows what counter measures should be
taken I don't agree with the decision of
the European Court Europe shouldn't be
deciding for Italy
Europe is unfortunately a very vague
concept it has huge economic value but
is weaker in other respects in terms the
judicial system Italy has the right to
move the way it feels is right crime is
different from country to country and
it's difficult to find a common line I
doubt that Bloxom Berg has the same
problems that were Spain every
government should deal with criminality
independently
you